Hello everybody, it's Dr. Kevin Conners, and let me get the chat up. Sorry, we're starting
a little late, had a little technical difficulties with everything. So you can see I'm working
from home again today and very casual because I just got in from the garden. So let's apologize
for my shaggy appearance, but let's get right to your questions. Or just a reminder to everybody
if you're new to this and you have questions go to holistichealthower.com where you could ask your
questions live and you could chat in your questions as well, but you could ask your questions so that
you'll make sure that they get on. So let's jump into the questions. First of all, do you recommend
your patients or anyone in general taking melatonin in larger doses? Either by therapeutic
for therapeutic purposes such as cancer, heart or brain related or other conditions or for
prevention. Thank you. So the answer is yes, but we typically only do that, I recommend that for cancer.
So melatonin in larger doses is really an oxidative agent, so it's important to understand
things that you would do for cancer can be very different than things that you would do for
other health conditions. You would normally, if you did not have a diagnosis of cancer, you would
want to reduce oxidative stress because oxidative stress can be a cause of cancer. So your body has a
way to limit and reduce oxidative stress. So what is oxidative stress? Oxidative stress is
classified as what are called reactive oxygen species, reactive nitrogen species.
That bond to your cell membranes that bond to your mitochondrial membranes, your other organelles,
can damage organelles, can damage the nucleus of the cell and can be a cause of cancer. So those
are oxidative agents. So typically most poisons and pesticides and toxins and heavy metals and
even endotoxins that your body produces can produce oxidative stress. Your body produces oxidative
stress through its metabolic processes normally and oxidative stress has benefits. So when your body
produces reactive oxygen species, it's typically for the purpose of killing pathogens or it's a
byproduct of metabolism. So it can be just a byproduct of metabolic pathways and then it's reduced. So
those oxidative oxygen species are reduced through anti-oxidant agents that your body produces. So
your body produces the made antioxidant agent that your body produces is glutathiled. That is your
number one intracellular antioxidant. It reduces those reactive oxygen and nitrogen species to
substances and gets rid of them and helps your body get rid of those. We also produce glutathione
in the liver helps with phase 1, phase 2 pathways in the liver. So normally you have this tug-of-war
between oxidative stress and reducing oxidative stress. You have this tug-of-war between
oxidants and antioxidants. Remember, nothing in your body, let's say, is all bad. So it has a
purpose. So the purpose of having reactive oxygen species in your body is that you will have
it will help kill pathogens. So let's say if I have a bacterial infection, my body will actually
make more reactive oxygen species to help the immune system kill pathogens and so it has a benefit.
However, there's a danger it just being out of balance. So if you're ever, it's just all about
balance. So you have this balance of oxidative agents and a balance of antioxidants that your body makes.
Now we are told if you look at different nutritional circles, you're told that you should be eating tons
of antioxidants because you're exposed to so many reactive oxygen species. And I would agree with
that. So normally you are exposed, okay, let's say, let's say 200 years ago. Well, it's not even true
then because people were to colonize it, produce reactive oxygen species and stuff too. But in today's
society, we are exposed to a lot of chemicals that our ancestors were never exposed to. Those are
oxidizing agents and those can be cancer causers. So our cancer causers because they damage cell
membranes, they damage mitochondrial membranes, they damage the nucleus of the cell and they can cause
the cell nucleus being damaged to go into rapid replication so it can be actually a cause of cancer
because of a lot of ill health. So taking a lot of antioxidants can be good advice for someone
to prevent cancer. So why am I saying this or talking about melatonin? Because melatonin
at a normal dosage, which would be like three milligrams per day, to help you fall asleep, taking
that half hour to an hour before bedtime that will help you go to sleep. And at three to six milligrams
a day, 10 milligrams a day, it's considered, it has an antioxidant properties as well. So it functions
as an antioxidant as well. But in a higher dosage, we're talking 40, 60, 80, 120, 200, 200 milligrams doses
that it functions as an oxidized agent. So there are certain nutrients that at higher doses
actually function as an oxidized agent, not an antioxidant. That can, that is important to know
that because you know too much of a good thing can be a bad thing. So something in a different dose
could actually have a completely different function in your body. It's also important to know that
because if you are, if you are doing the, doing the an oxidative therapy for cancer, so understand
if you're trying to treat cancer, cancer cells by the, by the very act of bead in rapid replication
are producing relatively unhealthy cells. Let's say not as healthy as normal cells. And because of that,
they're already producing a lot of oxidative stress. So they're already near that lethal dose of
oxidative stress, which would kill, which could kill them. So we can actually harness
that knowledge and add oxidizing agents to that person, not antioxidant. So first of all,
without cancers, trying to take antioxidant so they don't get cancer. But once you have a diagnosis
of cancer, you don't necessarily want to be taking antioxidants. You want to be taking oxidizing
agents. So many alternative therapies are oxidizing, uh, therapy therapies.
Leandro B17, that's an oxidizing therapy, protocells that oxidizing therapy,
high dose vitamin C is an oxidizing therapy, high dose melatonin is an oxidizing therapy,
high dose vitamin E, especially delta, total treat all, is an oxidizing therapy.
Um, so it's understand that's a natural approach. Actually, chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent.
That's how chemotherapy works. It it increases oxidative stress. And it will help
keep over cancer cells because they're already near that lethal dose where healthy cells have that
balance. And their mitochondria is our functioning well and they're producing a lot of glutathiles. So
they're getting rid of oxidative stress. Cancer cells have less than healthy mitochondria. They're
not producing enough glutathilum to get rid of oxidative stress. So they're already producing a lot of
wrapped amounts of species in their near that lethal dose of self-debt of lysis because of my
oxidative stress. And if you could give them more oxidative stress, gives chemotherapy, you will kill
cancer cells prior to killing healthy cells. Now, the good thing about an alternative oxidative
therapy for cancer is that it does, it spares the healthy cells. So it doesn't damage healthy cells
where chemotherapy couldn't kill healthy cells as well. So answer, long answer to the question.
Do I recommend high dose melatonin for cancer, heart or brain related issues?
It's only a partial, yes. I only recommend it for cancer. High dose melatonin for heart or
brain related issues, I wouldn't use it for that because you're increasing oxidative stress. There's
no reason why you'd want to increase oxidative stress to cardiac tissue. I'd have to see some studies
on why you would do that. I have not seen any studies. And I've not seen any studies on why you would
increase oxidative stress to unbrained cells, unhealthy brain cells. I don't believe it functions as an
anti-inflammatory. So only for cancer is the answer to that question that took me 10 minutes to answer.
Sorry. Next question, by 10 year old daughter has been diagnosed by ultrasound testing with radodes
in her toes. She doesn't seem to have it anywhere else. It's probably been years that she has had it,
but symptoms started to flare or recently turned around purple, color and sore.
It seems like it obviously is a blood flow problem. It is year-round symptoms, not just what it's cold,
but winter is a little worse. Besides keeping it warm and foot massages, what suggestions do you have
that you could look into as far as the why she has this and what you could do about it? While I don't
radodes has similar properties to, it's definitely a reactive condition. You need to react to
different things. So a lot of people will have radodes in cold weather. This person says it doesn't
make a difference. So winter, same thing, hot cold doesn't make any difference. So you have to look
for triggers. So similar to an autoimmune disease where you're looking for possible triggers.
So the constriction of the blood vessel has to do with a
sudden down-regulation of the H2 receptor and its connection to nitric oxide with radodes.
Similar type things with blood pressure issues with patients with high blood pressure
where they have a down-regulation of the H2 receptors, many times blockage of those
and a decrease of nitric oxide. Many times with blood pressure issues and cardiac issues it has
to do with either lime, heavy metal, Hpylori, much more common than it has to do with arterial
constriction due to cholesterol. But you can't have ethylene arteries for that, but with radodes it
has to do with a reactive constriction at the smooth muscle layer underneath the endothelial layer
of the vessels. So you have to look for triggers. So with radodes it's be the same
same investigation that you do if you have an autoimmune disease you're looking for what could be
the possible trigger that is setting off by flares. So same thing radodes you're having to flare,
what setting off that flare could be a food could be a toxin could be some sort of pathogen. So
typically a trigger that sets off a flare in an autoimmune disease or any of these immune
responses like asthma which is also an immune response you have to look for the triggers. The triggers
could be unrelated. So doing a food profile would be a good thing looking at that person's gut health
is really important. It could be pathogen related. A person could have a latent viral
infection that is a chronic viral infection that you know many times you can't get rid of a virus
out of your body. They can live in it or ganglion and they come out in opportunistic times. Could be
a antibodies to different other pathogens like bacteria and things like that. You could all
have antibodies to different chemicals. So every time you're exposed to that chemical now you
fire this immune reaction you get this reaction. So looking for those triggers.
Sometimes it's daunting. Like I can't figure out what set this off. I would start with diet.
I would start with the gut because many times even if the gut and the diet is it the trigger
once you clean that up? It's kind of like you're emptying out the bucket. You're cleaning up the
body and you're not going to be as reactive to other things that you may have antibodies against.
So cleaning up the diet, cleaning up the gut, healing the gut. I know many functional medicine doctors
start with that. And as I wouldn't say it's necessarily the cause of everything but certainly if
you do clean that up it can be it can decrease your reaction to so many other things. So it's the
wise place to start. I've been, let's see did I connect the chat. So you guys have any chat questions
make sure. Here's one that came in. Melatone causes eye detachment. It happened to me.
That's unfortunate. A retinal detachment probably maybe that would be very scary.
So again, a lot of people will think that there I'm you know be vitamins are good for me. So
I'm going to take a whole bunch of be vitamins. You know, again, too much of a good thing could be a
bad thing. Don't play with high dose stuff unless you're instructed to do so. I've been reading some old
blog posts on your website and have noticed a few places that reference a Connor's clinic prayer group
Facebook page. It appears this may be no longer exists. Is there such a group any longer? I would
love to join. Yes, you have to look up on Facebook. Yes, we do have our prayer group. Quite honestly,
we are not real active on it, but people will send different prayers to us and will post them.
And honestly, it used to happen a lot more, but we do every time I post somebody, if somebody emails
us, can you please pray for me? I'm having this problem or something. I may remove that person's name,
but then it will post it onto that Facebook prayer group. We always get multiple comments so
that people aren't looking at it. That will be praying for you. So anytime you could get prayer,
it's an important part of healing. So it still is active and I think it's just called
Cutters Clinic Prayer Group if you just search Facebook if you want to join. Does vitamin E increase
estrogen? I have estrogen positive breast cancer. Vitamin E has been shown to be actually
helpful in breast cancer. Matter of fact, higher dose, even the top cause for all,
vitamin E can be a function in just exactly what I was talking about before in a oxidative mode
for breast cancer. In fact, I just saw several studies a few months ago about
high dose delta-tocoltrino and high dose alpha and mixed to cofferals for breast cancer,
showing that it increases oxidative stress to breast cancer cells and spares all healthy cells
so it can be a nice adjunctive therapy. Of course, most of the studies with nutrients are studies
that are done concurrently with chemotherapy just so you know. It's hard to get very many studies
approved at least in the United States in recent years that are going to be for specific nutrients
and cancer without them being combined with chemotherapy. So usually they're looking for does
curcumin increase the efficacy of chemotherapy? Well, that's what they're let's say if the study showed
you know, 100 women taking chemotherapy and then another 100 men taking chemotherapy plus
curcumin and the ones that took the group that took chemotherapy plus curcumin had a better success
right then they're going to give the credit to the chemotherapy that the curcumin actually
helps the chemotherapy work better instead of that the curcumin actually killed the cancer cells.
Well, who cares? I mean, it's just is what it is. I mean, we are a capitalistic society driven by
money governed by who has the most money and it happens to be the pharmaceutical companies right now.
So the studies that I saw were vitamin E, both the Toconferols and Tocotryanols with breast cancer
they were very very positive. So I would not say that you have to worry about vitamin E
increasing estrogen with the ER positive cancer given even just that study. Again, I would say if
you do have cancer and you are doing vitamin E, make sure you're not doing antioxidants.
It's very common that I see a person doing, you know, high dose antioxidants because they're maybe
their carpractor or nutritious told him to do that. Well, you have cancer. Well, antioxidants help
reduce the risk of cancer. So if you have cancer, you better take a whole bunch of antioxidants
and again, that's not really the right thought process. When you have cancer, you want to
increase oxidative stress to kill those cancer cells.
How do you feel about sauna therapy or infrared sunas if one has a malgum fillings? I have read
that detoxing in a sauna causes the mercury to leach and re-deposit deeper into the body
such as the organs. Can you comment on this please? I have not heard that. So I don't think that
that heat in a sauna is going to cause you to leach mercury from your malgum fillings. I do
know that heat like your much worse position drinking coffee with a malgum fillings. If you have
silver fillings, mercury fillings you're about to say you're drinking hot beverages. There's actually
if you haven't taken it out, I've ever seen a video on YouTube where they actually had a tooth
that was removed and put hot water on it like hot coffee or hot tea and then you could see the mercury
gas up by and off of that fillings. Pretty amazing. It's kind of scary. We shouldn't have mercury fillings
in our mouth and I know it's not always cost available for a person to have them removed and
we've had patients where the mercury is so embedded in every one of their teeth and literally
just have to have all their teeth pulled. So it's very unfortunate what a quote-unquote modern
dentistry has done to people over the last few decades especially with the mercury fillings.
But I would question whether what you read about the sauna is actually true.
If you're doing a sauna, I mean how would you measure that? Okay, so if you measured a person's
urine output of mercury and you did a sauna and their urine output of mercury was elevated after a sauna,
I would still say that I'm just guessing but I don't think physiologically that's coming from
your teeth. It's probably because of the heat and your sweating and your detoxing because of the
sauna, you're probably expelling mercury out of the tissues and out of the cells. So I would think
that would be a good thing. So otherwise how would you measure the sauna deep-positive mercury elsewhere?
I think that I'd be careful with mercury fillings is, first of all, like I said,
hot prep or just things like that but how do you get around that? You got to get your mercury fillings
removed. The other thing I'd be careful about is you see really strong key laders
and you should be careful about using really strong key laders if you have metal implants too,
like nickel implants like a broken bowl or something like that. Titanium, at least in my experience,
has been people haven't had as much reaction to titanium so there are some people that have had
reaction to titanium. But mercury fillings are bad. Yes, it's really a tough call. I don't think
sauna is going to make it worse. Certainly you can try to prevent that if you think that that is
an issue with you by doing more mild key laders and supporting your liver detox pathways. The benefit
of the sauna is to help support detoxification through your skin so it takes some pressure off your
liver and your kidneys. I don't think from a physiological standpoint it's going to draw
your mercury from your teeth. Okay, so next question. Why do you recommend that cancer patients
don't take glutamate? Well, because in general cancer is fed through multiple different sources.
Cancer cells are, remember, rapidly replicating and because they're rapidly replicating, they're
very hungry. So they need a lot of fuel in order to continue their metabolic processes,
continue to live and thrive and to continue to replicate. So they're hungry cells. So typically
cancer is fed through glucose. So if you remember, seventh grade biology, glucose goes through
glycolysis and produces two endpoints that then produces two ATP and then it goes into the
crab cycle and produces a lot of ATP. That's how you produce energy. So glucose is how you make energy
and that's how you run cells. So cancer tends to grow through glucose through glycolysis but not
through the crab cycle. Oddly, it ends up because of the excess oxidative stress in the cell. It starts
to use lactate as a fuel and it's very inefficient but to cancer cells because they're rapidly replicating,
they're not functioning well and they're functioning inefficiently. So that's why you'd say
cancer patients should stay away from sugar, which I agree. All cancer patients should stay away from
sugar. But as cancer is growing, it can use other things for fuel and it can be used to be an
amino acids. Glutamine and methionine are probably the two most common amino acids that cancer could
use for fuel. Glutamine is also an amino acid that's unique in that it helps stimulate growth,
rapid growth. That's why you would take glutamine to help heal epithelial cells of your gut. So
typically glutamine as a supplement is used as a gut healing supplement because your gut cells
use that to help replicate new cells and you could heal your gut quite well by using glutamine. It's
a beneficial substance to help turn over cells in the gut and heal cells in the gut. Well just
that little bit of knowledge should help the average person just go, yeah, I don't want to help
grow cancer cells, especially if you have an endocarsidoma of that glutamine would typically feed
quite well. So I typically recommend that you don't necessarily need to go on a glutamine-free diet
because that's impossible. You need protein in order to make the right variety of lymphocytes to
kill cancer cells. But you don't need to be taking excess glutamine in supplements. So it's not
uncommon that we have a cancer patient come to us and they maybe did some study on, well,
I need to heal my gut because now I need to get, all right, I've got this diagnosis of cancer.
Maybe they're working with a nutritious and said, with diagnosed cancer, we really need to heal
your gut. We need to get you on glutamine. I think that's the very wrong thing to do. Cancer patients
should not be taking excess glutamine like that in a supplemental form because it couldn't literally
be fueling the cancer. So typically, I say no glutamine for cancer patients, they're in full
remission and now we're working on some other cobalt rigidies. It just makes sense to stay away from
something that could possibly fuel it. Next question. What is H. Pylori and how do you treat it?
We've talked about H. Pylori and our holistic health tower a lot. I have some, I think, good videos
on our website too. And use our website as a resource, cuttersclinic.com. It can be helpful. You can
search for all sorts of things on there. And one is H. Pylori. So H. Pylori is short for Helico
Bacter Pylori. It's a bacteria. Grab negative bacteria that normally is a part of your normal
gut flora in balance, but it can become out of balance and opportunistically take over quite quickly.
It is the number one bacterial infection worldwide according to the World Health Organization.
It's the number one cause of stomach cancer. It's the cause of stomach ulcers.
But it can cause other things as well. I mentioned earlier that it is a major cause of endothelial
disorders and endothelial disease, high blood pressure, you know, myocardial imparction, etc.
It could be a cause of other cancers. And it is preventable. So it's usually the opportunity for it to
flourish tends to stem primarily from hypochlorhydria. So when people have a decreased stomach acid
production, then they end up with H. Bluori starting to flourish in the stomach and then it spreads from
there to other organs and into the intestines and systemically. It could cause an array of problems.
So you want to get that in order. The worst thing that people do is they go on a PPI or take
toms or something like that. Probably one of the worst drugs ever created because it just, if
somebody's out at PPI, it's pretty much guaranteed you got H. Bluori. Just hand style. You don't even
take the test support. Everybody should treat as if they have H. Bluori on a regular basis. And your
number one treatment for H. Bluori is make sure you get your stomach acid back into balance, support
your digestion by taking H. C. L with digestive enzymes and take a H. Bluori type supplement.
You're one of the best things is garlic and burberry to kill H. Bluori. That is my favorite. So that's why
one of my favorite nutritional supplements on the planet is burberry because it is a great killer of
H. Bluori. It can be a killer cancer. I want you to do different things. So if you want more
information on H. Pylori, how to deal with it? How to understand high-pochlorohedria, which is a
decreased stomach acid, go to our website, search high-pochlorohedria, search H. Pylori and I think
there's multiple blog posts that look back and forth and give you details on how to help yourself with that.
Can a person who does not present with cancer safely use glutamine for the gut or should everyone stay
away in case they have cancer cells in their body? No, I don't think everybody should stay away from it.
If you don't have a diagnosis of cancer, glutamine can be fantastic for healing your gut.
But just like so many supplements, remember a lot of supplements are supposed to be supplements. They're
supplementing your diet. It's not something you'd stay on forever. Some people are very routine and
they'll be taking these supplements for decades. While some of those might be wise, maybe
you're going to be supplemented. Maybe you need something because you have heart issues and you're
on something for a certain condition. Alglue to mean is not one of those things that you stay on for a
long period of time. You should be doing other things to deal with your gut, too. You should be
investigating why you haven't got problems. You should be investigating. Are you causing inflammation
through dietary means or toxic means or something? You're eliminating those. But then you're trying to
heal your gut, too. So you're using other things other than glutamate, just glutamate. You're using
alloy and deglycerized licorice and slippery element. There's products that have a mixture of those
kind of things in it with some glutamate, but it's not that you take all the time. So it's taking
for a period of time while you're healing your gut, but while I say you wouldn't take it continuously
all the time, you are probably continuously damaging your gut. So trying to investigate and reducing
the continuous damage you might be doing and then working out of gut healing protocol
multiple times per year that you could help heal that. I have gastritis and almost no stomach
and pH of six. I cannot take HCl because of gastritis so far andoscopy shows no H-pilora. What's your
suggestion of burberry and garlic? I will view the video. So go to our blog post on hypochloridria.
If you already have a lot of damage to the lining of the stomach and even possibly an ulcer,
you won't be able to tolerate HCl. So I have protocol that you should start with, that you should
back away from HCl and you try apple cider vinegar prior to your meals. Remember you only take HCl
or apple cider vinegar right with or right before your meal. So you're not leaving HCl and your
stomach by itself in an empty stomach nor are you leaving nor are you putting apple cider vinegar
in an empty stomach either. You might put it in an empty stomach but you're eating something right
away. Otherwise it's going to cause irritation especially if you have a lot of damage stomach cells,
especially if you have a damaged type of lining caused with an ulcer. I wouldn't trust that you don't
have H-pilora. The tests that are out there for H-pilora are not exact. So you really have to diagnose
that based upon your symptom picture. But if you can't tolerate the apple cider vinegar,
then you have to go into just healing mode. Declosterized licorice will be things like that that I mentioned
should be started for a few weeks and then every week or so you try using apple cider vinegar
before your meal. Once you could tolerate that, you do that for several weeks while you're still
working on healing that got and then you try to switch to HCl and hopefully you'll be able to tolerate
at the time as your stomach cells heal. So that's kind of how you'd walk through that on that
blog post I kind of walk through that. All right. If I already know I have leaky gut,
do I have to run the Cyrex Array 2? So the Cyrex Array 2 test for anybody knows what that is.
This person knows what it is. It's for intestinal permeability. And it's easy to go, well,
I already know I have intestinal permeability. So I know I need to run that test. Well,
the benefit of running that test is that there's several different levels of intestinal permeability.
So when we talk about leaky gut, we talk about damage of what are called the tight junctions.
So your your epithelial cells bond together like this and when you have inflammation in the gut
because of food sensitivities, because of damage, because of chemicals, food colors,
all this, whatever, all these different things that damage your gut, the cause inflammation,
you could have a weakening of that tight junction. And that separates those cells
and you could have things get into your bloodstream through those cells that never was supposed to
get into your bloodstream. Larger protein breakdowns, larger peptides,
that never should across the blood, the gut barrier. So you got this barrier breakdown.
So things are getting across the gut barrier. No, you're creating antibodies against things. That's
how you develop food sensitivities. So you have sensitivity to gluten, you have a sensitivity
dairy, sensitivity to all these different things. Why is that? Because you have a damaged gut.
So that is typically how leaky gut is explained. And that's true. But that's actually only level one
of gut permeability. That's called pericelular permeability. So it's between the cells,
pericelular permeability. There's another level what's called transcellular permeability.
And that is actually the cell itself. You have cells that are so damaged. Things are actually
getting through the cell into the bloodstream. That's called transcellular permeability.
And Cyrex tests for different enzymes that are going to show that. And different antibodies that
are going to show that. So you're going to be able to differentiate whether you have pericelular
permeability or transcellular permeability. And then the last and worst situation is that you have
lipopolysaccharide production. So if you have lipopolysaccharide production because of permeability,
that's the worst case scenario. Because if you have lipopolysaccharide production,
lipopolysaccharides actually prove it to, in themselves, damage the blood brain barriers.
Now you're going to have blood brain barrier damage. So the worst situation is really
pericelular permeability, transcellular permeability, and lipopolysaccharide production.
So it's just a different, it's, it's, so the Cyrex array too is telling you what is going on.
It's not telling you why. It's not telling you like, you know, it's because you're exposed to this
chemical. Or because you're continuing to eat gluten when you have celiac disease. Or because you,
it's not telling you that, but it's telling you what you have. So there's certain antibody tests
that tell you, you know, that give you basically a diagnosis. And that would be the Cyrex array
too. So it can be beneficial to know that. You could, you have to kind of treat the person a little
bit differently that way. If you know they have pericelular damage too. Same thing with the Cyrex array
that's telling you, do I have self antibodies? Cyrex array 7x? Do I have neural self antibodies?
There's some lab core tests that test for different systemic antibodies. So those are, those are
autoimmune tests to get a diagnosis. So if I run Cyrex array 7x and I have antibodies to
mileage, she sells, you know, that I have de-biolination taking place every time I have an immune flare.
So I'm exposed to a trigger whether it be a food or a chemical. And my immune system is flared.
It's very possible that I'm going to have more de-biolination. This is what causes MS. This is
what causes any de-biolinating disease and dysfunction that goes along with that. So to know that you
have that can be beneficial. So there's labs that you'd run to get a diagnosis, but that doesn't
solve the problem. Oh my gosh. Okay, I have antibodies to mileage. She sells good a sex. I either have
full-blown MS or pre-MS. Okay, well, what do you do about it? Now you got to figure out your
triggers. So there's other antibody tests that you test for like a chemical antibody test or a
pathogen antibody test. That's array 11 and array 12 or food antibody tests to dig into what are the
triggers that are causing this damage. So array two is one of those that tell us, you know,
the level of damage to the gut that the Cyrex array three x it is now called test for all sorts
of different peptides of gluten. I'm already off of gluten completely. Or maybe you could skip that
test. There are a four tests for gluten cross-reactants because you may be reacting to something because
it's across-reacted to gluten. So that's a valuable test to run. So maybe it could skip the array
three x if you're already completely gluten free and you're religious about it. I tend to recommend
the three x for a lot of people because it helps them realize that they have, they do have antibodies
to gluten because many times people say, I can eat gluten and I don't have any problems. Well,
maybe you don't have any symptoms but it can be causing other problems. And then the array four is
the cross-contaminated gluten cross-contaminated and then a larger food panel would be the array's 10.
So there's different reasons why you run different labs. Some are to find a what and get a better diagnosis
to help you understand maybe why you have certain symptoms. Let's say you have joint pain all the
time. I can't figure it out. Well, if you knew you had arthritic antibodies or rheumatoid antibodies,
it would give you some clues to, okay, I got to get serious about finding my triggers and dealing with
this because I could end up with, remember there's three different levels of autoimmune disease,
I'm going to end up in level three with tissue destruction. I have tissue destruction because of
rheumatoid antibodies. That's never going to heal. That's never going to go away. I have swan-like
deformity of my fingers because of rheumatoid and you're never going to get that back.
And when you, the more tissue damage you have, the less chance you have a recovery of that tissue. So
all this information is on our autoimmune course if you want to dig deeper in that. Our courses are
only $50. We put a bunch of, a couple of months ago and we've had such a response that we've just left
them at that. So for $50 to start learning some videos, watching some videos and learning some
things about autoimmune disease can be extremely helpful. Highly suggest that.
Where can I start out of your website if I have several autoimmune conditions with an intake call?
So you can't. So if you know you have, if you want a self-treatment, we made the courses to
educate people. So I made the courses because not everybody needs another doctor, okay? You don't
need me. I don't want people to need me. So I want people to learn as much about
self-care as they can. I just think we're moving into age the more that you can know to better take
care of yourself and your family the better off you're going to be. And so many things with an
autoimmune disease has to be your, you want to put on your own Sherlock home hat and try to figure
some of this stuff out. I can run some tests, I can give you some hints, I can educate you as much
as possible, but ultimately you have to do the work. So the autoimmune course might be a good place
to start. By all means, if anybody wants to talk to me, you can schedule a time, you start with
what's called a case review. You can do that as well. And I can point you in different directions.
I have a lot of stuff on our website, but that's most of the stuff on our website is cancer-related.
To dig deeper in autoimmune things, to enjoy that autoimmune course that I mentioned,
watch the other holistic health hours too. They're all indexed quite nicely as well.
All right, thank you for a great holistic health hours. Are we starting a little bit late?
I get your questions and remember to go to holistichealthour.com. You can ask your questions
on there so that hopefully we'll for sure get them on the call or chat them in like you did.
And go to cuttersclinic.com. That's where you'll see the courses on the top of the website.
You click on the different courses, pay for them right on the line, start them.
Understand, it's not a course like I have to do A, B, C and then pass this test or something.
I don't know why we call them courses. We just didn't know what to call it. So we came up with courses.
So it's kind of like an education. I think so. Maybe that scares people. Maybe they don't want
to do it because they think it's an education. But then I don't want them to do it. They don't want
to educate themselves, then don't do it. Forget it because you have to take charge of your own health here.
It's very, very important. So God bless everybody. We'll see you next week and have a fantastic
Fourth of July. Bye-bye.